nothing is true everything is permitted
why can't religions be that fun
Assassin's Creed 3 right so Assassin's
Creed 3 is actually the fifth game in
the main Assassin's Creed story arc and
in Assassin's Creed 3 you play as a new
assassin named Connor
so Assassin's Creed 3 takes place in
colonial America Connors half Native
American so you have that whole uh the
government's taken over Native American
land which is bad so he wants to protect
that and defend that but the Templars
are taken over you know the government
he can't have that
thus we enter a new chapter in the
Assassin's Creed games and is it an
impressive chapter for the most part
yeah it really is first of all you have
combat now the combat in this game is
all fleshed out I had heard that they
actually had combat tactics when you're
fighting guys so no more spam counters
which for the most part that's actually
accurate I still spam counter you will
sit there for a solid minute waiting for
a guy to attack you so you can just push
the counter button and kick his ass if I
can compare the combat in this game to
any other game I would compare it to
Batman Arkham City you're kicking the
piss out of guys you push your counter
button he will counter no matter what
he's doing you can kick the piss out of
that guy to take on groups of ten guys
and just clean house if you ever played
Batman Arkham City and just kick the
living [ __ ] out of ten guys and you're
like that would be really cool of Batman
actually killed people here you go
Assassin's Creed 3 take a tomahawk to
their face and not only is the combat
really fun to do but there are a lot of
missions to do in this game you only
have two city zones in this game you
have Boston in New York that was kind of
a bummer I wanted a little more but you
do have to wilderness zones which sounds
fun and they have this whole hunting
aspect in there but ultimately you hunt
animals for a little while and you take
their pelts and you sell them and you're
like all right well let's just go back
to killing people that's right we are so
desensitized as a civilization that the
killing people is just a little more fun
than killing Bobcats and hunting
squirrel and if I'm going to touch on a
bit of a bomber is its colonial America
so the building's really weren't that
tall most of the buildings are scouring
across in this game are about two
storeys tall it feels like a really
trivial gripe but I'm just saying in the
other Assassin's Creed games where the
buildings were enormous you're now in
the early stages of America you know
buildings are a couple stories tall so
you usually just run through the streets
feels like a bit of the Assassin's Creed
vibe was just taken back a little bit a
bit nerf however you get a ship in this
game you're like it's a big pirate ship
and it is badass
that's right ships like this they get
women's names that you can't name your
ship I think you should be able to but
you can't I would an in mine soul
sucking [ __ ] and it would be awesome
but we are doing these naval missions
you're steering your big ship you
honestly feel like just being like oh oh
I rich life for me not a pirate's I mean
you're you're pretty legit human being
in this game you're not a pirate that
being said you feel like a pirate and
they ain't bad if they want to make
expansions for Assassin's Creed 3 give
me more naval combat because yeah the
pirate's life it is officially for me
and if you want to talk about some fun
in Assassin's Creed 3 the multiplayer
that is some fun [ __ ] you have your
target you are someone else's target and
you just have to blend in and not get
killed in time to kill your target
they're doing the same thing so it's
funny everyone's trying to walk like
NPCs and make like 90-degree turns or
just sit on benches and be really
incognito until you see your target and
you just beeline it and stab them in the
back now in terms of the story Connor is
a really cool character I liked Ezio the
best probably because Ezio has had a few
games in a very large lifetime story
however it's cool to see Connor go from
this really young brash do to this
badass by the end it's cool to see him
grow in the course of a game I did feel
that in Assassin's Creed 2 the first
story with Ezio Ezio was still you know
he was badass by the end but he was also
still Ezio he was still a cooze hound
hurry kid Connor at the end of
Assassin's Creed 3 is not the same
person he was when he was inducted as an
assassin in Assassin's Creed 3 I like
seeing that I like character growth I
was hoping to interact with more
historical figures by that I mean I was
really hoping that Thomas Jefferson was
in this game because he's awesome
you do interact with a few historical
figures George Washington being one of
them Sam Adams you interact with him
because he has good beer however I'm
just gonna come out and say this hate
them Ken ways one of the greatest
characters I've ever played as in an
assassin's Creed game I wouldn't mind an
entire game being dedicated around him
it was all smarmy and cool he was like
if Jon Hamm was in an assassin's Creed
game not gonna lie I think I had a bit
of a man crush on this dude Haytham
Kenway the man however Assassin's Creed
3 technologically speaking what's not
great about it bugs I don't mean insects
I mean programming bugs there are a lot
of them in this game it could be little
things like when my character knocked on
a door showed a close-up of his
and it was a Redcoat and I'm like my guy
is not a Redcoat nor is he wearing a
coat that is remotely read so why was
that a Redcoat then there are other bugs
like it's hard to pick items up that
shouldn't be too hard to pick up another
example is one character was talking to
me and his mouth wasn't moving he's just
like right so are you ready to move out
we're going to go there we're gonna kill
these people and a couple of these
glitches in a game like this I would
understand that but enough happened in
this game toward it's apparently worth
addressing in my video just like these
little frustrations that are in the game
where you're like why is it bugged but
game developers apparently don't realize
is the seed of doubt that bugs plant in
the players brain because then I'll be
going I'm not wanted i'm totally
incognito I walked by some red coats and
they flip out on me to start kicking my
ass and I think to myself well did I do
something to make that happen or is that
just another game but I mean if there
were no game bugs in the game I'd be
like oh yeah my character has dark skin
its colonial America so they're gonna
kick my ass
racist NPCs my mind would go there but
since I saw glitches and bugs in the
game I now have to think of myself was
that a bug really takes you out of the
experience man I'm just saying however I
felt like the last five 10% of this game
was just like Oh wrapped up in I really
think they ran out of time and they
wanted to get this game out by the
holiday season so their life wrap it up
wrap it up wrap up the story wrap up
everything there are still glitches and
bugs in the game doesn't matter the
holiday season sticks around for nobody
wrap the game up so some of the glitches
and bugs weren't worked out and the game
just ended and by and large does it have
a none fulfilling ending if you haven't
heard by now people are kind of pissed
about the ending short version is yeah
it's a bit of a nun fulfilling ending
now if you remember I made a video about
the Mass Effect 3 ending and I don't
want to be known as the guy that just
[ __ ] about video game endings on the
internet however I do have a few things
to say about the Assassin's Creed 3
ending so if you want to hear a video
about the ending I will make a video
about the Assassin's Creed 3 ending
actually don't think Assassin's Creed 3
is going to be the last Assassin's Creed
game that happens but it is the last in
this story arc and if you're looking for
a fulfilling ending for this story arc
they should have done a little more even
among some of the bugs and the
unfulfilled ending Assassin's Creed 3
still has a badass character awesome
gameplay a [ __ ] ton of missions to keep
you entertained for days and days and
days a badass combat system fun naval
combat in an awesome multiplayer I will
say it's still worth buying at full
price I did and I don't regret it it's
there's a lot to do and it's fine right
so what is your favorite Assassin's
Creed game and would
you like to see me do a video all about
the ending in Assassin's Creed 3 and
kind of what I think about it so
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more